so senator tried to is who sits on the
Foreign Relations Committee joins me now
as well this evening senator Cruz thank
you very much for being here tonight you
hear all of this conversation and you
have been involved in trying to crack
down on some of the disinformation that
has come out of China tell me a little
bit about that effort senator well
Martha great to be with you you know
China has has long been the most
significant geopolitical threat the
United States faces and then and and the
communist government there engages in
repression a great engages in torture of
its citizens and we've always viewed it
as a human rights offense when they
censor and silence free speech we've now
seen that it's not just a human rights
threat but it is also a threat to
national security and global health when
it comes to Kate comes to this Wuhan
outbreak the Chinese Communist
government has direct responsibility
direct culpability or silencing for
covering it up when you had brave
position whistleblowers blowing the
whistle the Chinese government came down
on them they silenced them they did
everything they could to keep it quiet
and had they acted promptly that there
may well have been a possibility this
could have been contained as a regional
outbreak instead if the claim became a
global pandemic and and the lives lost
meant that many of those are directly at
China's doorstep I think there needs to
be direct accountability I introduced
legislation today to sanction Chinese
officials that are engaged in actively
censoring and silencing public health
information that endangered the lives of
Americans and people a globe that's what
I want to ask you because you know I
think everybody recognizes the the acts
the bad actor that China is in this
situation but where's the teeth you know
how do you make it matter how do you
change their behavior with consequences
with an act of Congress well that there
needs to be accountability and look
first we have to defeat this crisis we
have to defeat the pandemic the public
health pandemic and and also the
economic crisis but afterwards there
needs to be a careful accountability as
to the communist governments in China's
responsibilities both for
covering it up and suppressing it and
that we know and also whether the
communist government played an
inadvertent part in the outbreak itself
you were just talking with secretary
Pompeii oh there were two State
Department cables that you reference
that occurred early on that described
two different labs in Wuhan within miles
of where the outbreak occurred that were
studying bat coronaviruses and and the
Chinese government does not want to
answer questions about whether they were
studying the novel the novel coronavirus
and whether it was an accidental escape
from their own labs there needs to be
real accountability because the State
Department was worried about the threat
of a pandemic from these labs before the
pandemic occurred and China that may be
part of the cover-up they don't want to
answer basic questions I think the
United States I think the world
community needs to insist on
accountability and consequences for
China's responsibility here I also think
we need to reassess China's role in our
supply chain far too much of our medical
products of our pharmaceuticals are
manufactured in China and they threaten
the lives of Americans cutting off vital
medicines we need to bring critical
critical infrastructure back to the
United States of America yeah I think
you know a lot of people would like to
see legislation around that and perhaps
incentives for pharmaceutical companies
that make it more reasonable for them to
produce these drugs at home that's what
they're gonna need in order to you know
create change for their shareholders and
the bottom line that obviously is a
concern to them as well senator Cruz
thank you sir good to see you tonight